I want to be very clear that I am NOT an
authority on the current financial scene
and and I don't think that I could
reasonably cast a blanket either
condemnation or defense for today's
corporate managers I think there are
plenty of companies that are honestly
and effectively run and the American
economy certainly continues to be a
great magnet for investment and for
faith around the world so when we
criticize sedates cover managers I think
in all fairness you know for myself I
see myself as no ideologue I see myself
as an historian first and foremost when
it comes to analyzing the evidence being
honest
looking at all sides of an issue so when
I bring that to the modern world I have
to say you know we can't go over the top
in any direction but one of my concerns
one of my concerns has someone has
studied the 19th century and is now
looking at today's world is the distance
that exists between for example
Cornelius Vanderbilt's attitude toward
his responsibilities as the chief
executive of a corporation toward his
shareholders and what and again you know
appears to me not as a student but as it
is a informed observer the attitude of
some CEOs in today's large corporations
specifically when it comes for example
to compensation
Vanderbilt took no salary and no bonuses
as a chief executive of his corporations
the only remuneration he got was in
dividends now youyou can't duplicate
that model today because today's
investors expect the share price to grow
they expect the ask the actual asset to
increase in value and that's what
investors look for dividends are a
secondary issue at best in Vanderbilt
today and I look at that in my book the
theories of why this
so at the time dividends are what
investors wanted so in order to have a
healthy company to have a highly valued
company you had to return a large share
of your profits every year in large
dividends to your investors Vanderbilt
was a major often majority shareholder
in his companies and so his only income
came from dividends which meant that he
had to make his company's profitable
year in and year out and that he only
got the remuneration that came from
running a healthy productive company
that was profitable in today's world the
you know there's many different
companies with many different
compensation structures and yet we often
see that you know this a very different
attitude
for example because growth and the the
sort of vaguer
ideas about what represents what what
contributes to the value of a share
potential you know market share growth
and the potential for growth a lot of
things that don't have to do with
actually having a healthy underlying
financial outlook for the the company a
CEO can be rewarded by creating the
perception that a company is healthy and
growing and promises great things in the
future and actually could potentially be
running it into the ground and yet gets
rewarded because he's creating the he or
she is creating this this perception in
Vanderbilt today of course Vanderbilt as
a major shareholder would benefit by
perceptions as well but again most of
his income most of his wealth came from
steady return on on the profits in his
company a share of the profits in his
company whereas in today's world that's
not necessarily the case another
troubling factor which of course creates
a potential for CEO not not doing right
by shareholders
in the end another potential problem is
the fact that in the modern world
management is removed from ownership and
CEOs today often have the ability to to
basically pick their own boards that the
the oversight over with the CEO and the
other executives are doing is often very
limited often shareholders have very
little say over who is managing their
company and sometimes this leads to this
is fine you know you have a professional
manager who's conscientious and does
great things with the company we can't
make blanket statements and yet the
removal of management from ownership
creates a potential for for self dealing
a conflict of interest and throughout
history we repeatedly see this so this
is troubling to me in a way that for
example the sheer size of executive
compensation is not as troubling of
course I love the ideal of having a very
equal society but in a corporate
capitalist economy which troubles me
most is when there's a conflict of
interest and the people who are running
a company have no oversight and there's
no one looking over their shoulder
there's no one their answer in practical
terms that they're answerable to and
when you have that situation then you
have somebody who's potentially taking
money that rightfully belongs to the
shareholders in the terminology that
they use invaluable time is very
interesting they would refer to the
shareholders as the owners they didn't
talk about you know the shareholders
they talked about owners and they refer
to the company as your property in their
annual statements for example and this
is very important this is having that
attitude as a CEO keeps you honest and
being able to run the management out of
town if necessary you know having that
threat is important I think to keep
something healthy we have that in
politics and we have enough trouble in
politics as it is and we need that in
corporate
as well so I don't want to make a
blanket condemnation it's just that of
today's executives when we do have
problems and we do have controversies I
often think it's connected to the fact
that a lot of management of large
corporations are no longer answerable to
the people actually own the company and
when that happens I think that's when
trouble often steps in